here on the outskirts of bandung
a city on indonesia's main island java
something is being cultivated that could
be of great value
mushrooms they rarely draw much
attention
there are many species with many varied
properties
some are nourishing others contain
medicinal agents
here they're the raw material for an
innovative kind of textile
mushroom is super ingredient to become a
sustainable
future ladder because it grows
mycelium a vegetative part of the fungus
that can mimicking
perfectly like leather without any
pu or pvc or any chemical content based
material
adi resa nugro comes from a family of
mushroom farmers
in 2012 he and some colleagues founded a
startup for gourmet mushrooms
but they quickly changed tack to focus
on mycelium
they're committed to developing a
sustainable and animal friendly fashion
industry
compared to animal leather mycelium
leather is having a really huge
advantage
in environmental impact for example
we consume less water we don't have to
kill
animal we can do vertical farming so we
can save some space
and it also emits a really less
carbon emission they feed their
mushrooms with organic waste such as
sawdust
their company microtech sources it
locally
what's waste for the wood mill is a
recyclable treasure here
the sawdust is cleaned with steam
then it's mixed with tiny mushroom
spores
they consume the sawdust and at the same
time on the outside of the sawdust
blocks
they produce tightly woven mycelium
which can be harvested within a few days
the process uses a fraction of the water
used in standard leather production
less than one-tenth this has caught the
attention of yokohalanda
he makes and sells shoes many of course
are made of leather
but these days he's keen to find
alternatives
the leather industry is one of the
biggest contributors for carbon emission
and we see that as as long as we keep
selling for
leather footwear and then as the cells
grew we keep damaging the environment
and then
it came to a realization that we need to
find a
sustainable solution at first he bulked
at the notion of mushroom level
but his team have now learned how to
work with it
mycelium fabric is breathable flexible
and robust
it can last for years and it's an
eco-friendly sustainable product
companies around the world are
discovering its advantages
mycelium shoes still have a long way to
go they're not yet widely available
they're not yet a mass market product it
has still
higher cost because due to the scale
meaning that
we still produce it in limited quantity
it's a learning curve but as an
innovation
company we need to learn and i think the
future will be
very bright for us adi reza nugroho and
his team
agree they're busy ramping up production
they already have orders for as far
ahead as 2027.
so currently we are producing 2 000
square feet of mycelium leather per year
however the demand is really huge so we
need to double
down our capacity in order to keep up
with the demand
the company is growing it used to have
just five employees
now it has 30. it monitors carefully the
quality of its output
even testing samples to destruction
it also breeds its own mushrooms and
works on optimizing them for the task at
hand
it gets some outside funding for its
pioneering research
that helps sustain the startup
adi reza negro will go the extra mile
with his mushroom leather shoes
it's a great idea whose time has come
you